start thinking like the man that you are  or talking to okay and this is what i  mean  when you go hook up with this man  stop thinking of it as a little  date night a little snuggle that okay  he's seeing it as a hookup so when you  go hook up you need to see it as sex and  you're out your shift is over baby  you're gone she advises women  that some men are only in it for sex and  you know these men they don't care about  you personally and they they don't want  anything deeper out of relationships or  out of life probably and her great tip  is to adopt the same mentality so stoop  to  the lowest common denominator  give up on wanting something more  something better out of life and out of  your relationships every day i get a  little more desperate  and desperate situations yield the  quickest results as the man descends  into selfishness nihilism emptiness  superficiality descend with him and then  at the end  you'll both be equally alone and  miserable success  i guess